a really great community has been built
on the internet from our viewers and
listeners over 4000 of you are now
subscribed to our reddit discussion
forum and I love checking out what
discussions our audience is having it's
a great way to get ideas for the show
and I was on there this morning a david
pakman.com slash read it checking out
some later some of the latest
discussions and I wanted to share a few
of them with you and encourage you to
participate as well from our reddit
discussion forum first and foremost
question what book should be on hotel
rooms instead or in addition to the
Bible and I think that this is
interesting because I recently read that
in Spain there is a hotel that has the
Declaration of the UN Declaration of
Human Rights in every bed side table
rather than the Bible and I sometimes at
hotels will find the Bible's that are
placed by the Gideons it's a group that
places Bibles in hotel rooms and I will
always put it outside like you know how
if you order room service you leave the
room service outside on the floor
outside your door I'll leave the Bible
outside on the floor outside the door
just thinking what if we made the
mandatory book like The God Delusion or
the Quran just to piss people off yeah
and I think they would noble I think in
some countries you probably would find
oh yeah instead of instead of a Bible
interesting discussion from our reddit
discussion forum some people suggesting
how about a book related to the location
where the hotel is also from our reddit
discussion forum should we limit
military spending by law military
spending a very important issue to many
in our audience and an interesting idea
the the limiting of military spending by
law and the problem with any of those
suggestions is that any arbitrary floor
or ceiling on spending can be
problematic in the right situation so I
write that we have a problem with
military spending but I don't know that
by law that's the way to sort of fix the
problem certainly would be tough I know
it's half of our discretionary budget
right now has to be lowered also from
david pakman.com slash read it the gap
in voter turnout the wealthy are much
more likely to vote than the poor and
middle-income and non voters are more
liberal than voters so not only do we
see racial disparities gender
disparities in terms of liberal and
conservative but we also are seeing
a sort of class disparity in that the
wealthy are more likely to vote and thus
it follows that be wealthier more likely
to have elected officials in place that
will be more sensitive to their needs
since after all they are the ones
choosing who gets elected we've talked
about this in many different ways over
time I'd imagine just you know on a very
basic level it's a lot easier for the
wealthy to take time off of work to vote
on a Tuesday to vote whereas if you're
poor and are reliant on that money yep
you can't really do that also from our
reddit discussion forum a discussion
thread about how human made sound
pollution in the ocean is killing marine
life relative related to a Vox article
this is not something I was aware of I
was aware of many other elements that
were killing marine life including all
the trash that is in our oceans but I
did not know much about sound pollution
and there's an interesting article on
Vox about that and lastly from our
reddit discussion forum social democrat
or democratic socialists pointing out
that I describe myself as a Democratic
Socialist not long ago and I jumped in
and very quickly said no what I mean is
I support social democracy I don't
really consider myself a Democratic
Socialist I sort of support social
democracy in a well-regulated capitalist
context and a lot of people jumping in
on this discussion because increasingly
people are actually thinking Pat about
different economic models and I think
that those are really great discussions
and one of the benefits of Occupy Wall
Street some people actually started
thinking about economic systems more
broadly I think we have to credit Bernie
Sanders too for even bringing that into
the conversation why Wall Street if you
can Bernie up
yeah no doubt about it join our reddit
discussion forum it's free it's a great
community and they're our moderators so
there really isn't too much trolling
trolls and people just hurling personal
attacks get banned and it is not a
violation of free speech because we are
not the government we are just an
Internet subreddit with a handful of
moderators helping out subscribe there